and hello
it's great to be here
that everything is working
everything's going great
took me a while to set up it looks a
little red in here a little rustic Maybe
little Western
that looks a little bright over there
that's a weird angle
just all the way up there could be
pointed more
and could be strained out so we'll we'll
probably not use that angle too much
but uh yeah here I am live
I got my little dummy over here
Cornelius
I use them to help set up the cameras
obviously not that well
that camera I'm disappointed in that
angle I really thought it was good it's
just in the center sort of but I'm
looking
like there's a lot of space behind me
right here where the camera's pointed at
that I'm not happy about
um so yeah I mean things are going great
um having a great time
you know
there's a lot going on in the news
there's a fire in Maui
you guys hear about the Maui fire
um
I would say a door is a perfect
instrument to communicate anger with
even if you're trying to hide anger a
door is gonna always
uh convey anger to you
so a door is
kind of a very sensitive instrument
whose primary purpose is to let you in
and out of places that you want to get
in and out of but whose secondary
purpose is
um
you know
communicating anger
the more Angry you are the more you're
going to slam the door you can't even
help it even if you're trying not to if
you're angry a door is going to bring it
out in you it's like this weak little
thing that just does whatever you want
just slam it just because
that's how you're feeling and you're
used to pushback but a door isn't going
to give you any pushback
it's unfortunate that that happens with
doors but if someone's angry they're
gonna slam a door you put a door in
front of an angry person they're gonna
slam it
it's just the perfect way to communicate
centrifugal force it's just small
inefficiencies and friction in the hinge
and air air resistance
but a door is going to convey a lot of
the energy and it's going to slam right
into the doorstop to convey your your
anger
Hans how do you like the Mexican culture
in Texas
um the Mexican culture in Texas is very
Mexican it's like really one of the most
Mexican cultures I've ever seen as a
Mexican culture in Texas
some really Mexican things happen here
in Texas like
we have good tacos
it's great how much work and effort they
put into a taco it's not just a novelty
item where they're like oh look we can
put these things together it's like oh
you can actually you know gain happiness
and pleasure and orgasmic Thrills in
your mouth from tacos this isn't just a
way to
um
put ground beef in your mouth it can
also be a happiness
a happiness sandwich a Mexican happiness
sandwich with all the best things Mexico
has to offer like avocado
fish
and other Mexican items
that go into a taco
so uh do you believe in ghosts I don't
believe in ghosts I think ghosts are not
real
Mexican culture in Texas is amazing and
you really got to be Mexican to fully
enjoy it
is Richmond north of
um
is Richmond north of Richmond really
controversial seems like it's loved by
many ignore by Mouse and hated by a few
journalists do you know anyone who
actually hates it is this like a
astroturfed
is this like the guy just going around
live chats just spamming this because
that was a very well formulated question
very well worded which makes me
suspicious
Mexican culture is great I I do not
believe in ghosts what is there nicest
thing
um I mean Joe Rogan gave me my career so
that's pretty nice how long have you
gotten any more tattoos no
okay so first things first Mexican
culture in Texas is a who and a hauler
there's a lot of Mexican stuff going on
in Texas it's one of the most Mexican
states that you can come to besides New
Mexico
um the the Mexican culture is great it's
just so Mexican
I just love Mexicans and Mexico and just
describing things as Mexican
because it just seems so happy and funny
and silly
um
I think
I think a lot of that has to do with
um
geopolitics and where Mexico is as a
country
I think it also has to do with
um
how they've been militarily
subdued
and they're not a threat to America so
it's like funny but like Canada Canada
could be a threat because they have
allies
uh if you attack Canada Britain's gonna
be like whoa that's not cool but if you
attack Mexico they're gonna be like
well
what are you gonna do
they're not really gonna care too much
because England and Canada have a
connection in Australia they're all
going to team up they'll be like come on
you can't pick on people that are
that are weaker than you we have a rich
culture
if you're going to be attacking people
based on their weakness
then we're not going to let you have our
new pop bands anymore
or they're going to be like we're gonna
team up on you
um
so yeah I mean I think Mexico is like
almost like a funny adjective
I I think that's
a good thing as well because you don't
want to be known as a country that's
like too serious takes themselves too
seriously I think Mexicans are
very good-natured and in good humor and
I think that's also part of why
describing things as Mexican can be
humorous
um but yeah I mean uh there's a lot of
things going on with Mexico
I uh obviously wish that Mexico could
stand up for itself and fight back
against America
um I think that would make the world a
better place if Mexico was strong a
strong Mexico makes the world strong
um
so maybe that's why I keep
calling things Mexican is because I want
Mexico to be
um a superpower and you know just being
like hey keep going Mexico
[Music]
um and I like to think about Mexico
so overall it's a good thing
would you ever join the Mexican cartel
Hans yes I would love the camaraderie
and the Brotherhood
and also to be fighting
for the rights of getting people high
[Music]
look at that angle I love how the the
curtains look in this camera this looks
like an anime shot
this looks sad
the [__] why does this look so dark
so the next question
it was
do you believe in ghosts ghosts
are not real
are
Even If ghosts weren't real for sure
people would come up with ghosts
because we like the idea of ghosts we
like having ghosts as a thing I'm gonna
change this [__]
[__]
um
what could we play
royalty free a lot of this royalty-free
[__] isn't even royalty free royalty
free they just know that you're gonna
play it and they can copyright you
um why don't I play one of my own
podcasts
while we wait for me to fix the lighting
uh let's play the one from Mario tanti
yesterday
pasture-raised gum okay that's crazy I
mean it takes an extra level of
[__] to do it and people are so used
to like corporatized volume hygienic
like sterilized I didn't touch the gum I
just dumped it okay the volume is on
why can't I hear it though that's weird
speakers USB speakers yeah
they don't have gloves on
they touch every piece of fish you know
yeah if you're eating sushi from someone
who wears gloves
that's bad Sushi that's why people
associate
how do you write jokes I uh think of
something that annoys me or like
something stupid that a TSA agent did or
like a flight attendant I think flight
attendants are the worst they're always
trying to
check your bags for no reason and uh
never gotten caught with anything
at the airport
no not really they let you bring in
pretty much anything nowadays yeah it's
true you could fly with weed and
mushrooms mushrooms and acid maybe pens
yeah it's just they just
they're they'll have like an attitude
sometimes and like I don't know I don't
I don't like Americans with power they
just try to take as much as they can
yeah you make 13 an hour yeah this is
this is how they get makeup for it yeah
you were not by yelling at people part
of Homeland Security yeah
okay
all right
so what's uh
where did you find your Jew guest
I uh found my Jew guest on
Jewish Tinder
Jewish lender
how many hours do you write per day
probably one hour and then every day I
try to write down whatever jokes that I
can think of
[Music]
hello hello hello
hello hello hello hello hello hello
hello hello hello hello hello I don't
know
how to do anything okay
um worst Comedy Club you have ever
played at probably the
uh
probably like Outdoors during the
pandemic
nice try I'm not gonna name a real
Comedy Club oh wow how did this shot get
worse there's a cable in front of the
camera now I'm gonna lift it
okay whatever
okay so uh
what else is going on the uh ghosts are
not real I think if uh people were
around without ghosts they would make up
ghosts because it's a fun way to think
because it helps some people think it
helps some people feel and go through
life and they're like oh yeah there's a
ghost following me or like oh there's a
ghost get out of this abandoned
warehouse where I might fall and hit my
head and die but your brain is just like
ghosts so I think it's a good way for
people to think
if they're like you know
their brain isn't working very good and
they can be like oh there's a ghost over
there so I'm not gonna go over there
um
so yeah I mean I think ghosts aren't
real so uh men Richmond north of
Richmond Richmond North men north of
Richmond I mean you're naming the
capital of the Confederacy so
I know Richmond has got a lot else but
why is that your demarcation of North
seems a little suspicious
like oh
it's north
of Richmond a lot of things are north of
Richmond
you could have said north of
Biloxi or the Bible Belt or whatever
um Richmond is a city that you know
brings up a lot of [__] for a lot of
people
so I don't know why he had to say north
of Richmond it's like oh all the
problems are north of Confederacy the
Confederacy was great we had it all
figured out with this whole slavery
thing
then all these Richmond north of
Richmond
had to come come around and stop us from
doing that now we're getting taxed a guy
like really hated taxes it's like
taxes
I mean you want zero taxes don't you
like the highway
and
you know clean water
and Wars
like how are you gonna get Wars without
taxes
so I don't know it's just like yeah I
mean it sucks that you work a lot and
you get paid a little I don't think it's
tax's fault I think there's other things
that we can tackle and yeah if there's
anything any inefficiencies in taxes we
should also figure that out but I don't
think it's
I don't think Nancy Pelosi is getting
rich off taxing people I think she's
getting rich off helping companies that
then [__] over people and use them as a
[__] piece of cattle to Farnam
oh
um
what about when you see the ghost of
your grandmother who just passed away
and you can smell her perfume and
everything that's probably your brain
being like Oh I miss my grandma let me
conjure her up as much as possible let
me try to will her into existence the
stimuli that I get from her so that I
can feel her presence again because it
is so painful without her so let me just
try to trick my brain into thinking
she's there
um our taxes are not going to highways
order schools or highways and our
schools are crap yes the taxes are all
going to making corporations make sure
that they can keep making money off of
us so I think we should stop spending
money on helping corporations and rich
people stay rich and we should use the
money to create the most awesome country
ever with beautiful railroads and
sidewalks and plumbing some of the best
plumbing in the world why not
I think that would be a fun thing to do
why not
we're gonna be all about the plumbing
thing for a while
we might have homeless people but at
least they can flush flush their [__]
it's going to be like a whole water park
underneath our city
um and we're just gonna be able to
flush anything you want any garbage
anything gross and disgusting you can
just throw it down our beautiful sewage
system and
we have a category for everything
and our whole society is built around
sewage it's like you just have to vote
via sewage you flush your vote down the
toilet
[Music]
um
and um
you transport yourself through the
sewage
I could have a whole sewage-based world
but instead we're just keeping our
highways and our sprawl and our giant
parking lots so that we can rich people
can make money off of us by selling Us
cars and gasoline
hey how's what's your favorite place to
eat in Austin probably golden tiger I
love the GT I'm there pretty much every
three times a week
um I love golden Tigers very delicious
um they make the best burgers I think I
think not a damn chance burgers are also
amazing
um
but they're never open
at 2 A.M or 1 30 a.m which is when
which is when I start feasting which is
when I start uh consuming My Flesh for
the day
public transit via water slide can we
January 6th the sysmonian and find out
what they're hiding
I think we've all seen Night at the
Museum and Night at the Museum too so we
know a lot about what they're hiding
so we have to uh really enjoy the the
beautiful crooning of a man who's just
tired of being taxed he's just so sick
of taxes
it's like when that time of year comes
around he's like damn why am I
in this tax bracket where I'm not
getting taxed that much
I have to spend I spent a lot in taxes
last year I don't think I did them right
I think I spent like ten thousand or
fifteen thousand in taxes because I spit
I sent them like ten thousand and
they're like you didn't pay Medicare and
all that so I was like okay here's four
thousand or five thousand
I think I [__] that up
but hey you're welcome that's charity
hopefully it goes to the right places I
funded or whatever okay I paid so much
in taxes fifteen thousand dollars
so
I'm gonna ride on the highway and [__]
I got to spray paint one
Highway Lane
what do I think about highways I think
they should be fewer I think they're
great in rural environments I think
they're horrible in cities I think you
should make a city for the people that
live there and not for people to zoom
right past
um I think highways create a lot of
traffic everyone has to get on it and
there aren't Alternatives built besides
the highway
I think highways are dangerous
um I think highways destroy
neighborhoods you know nobody wants to
live by a highway it's better to live by
a railroad than a highway although
living by a railroad isn't ideal either
um
I think uh highways are overused and
they're just a hammer that Texas uses
and everything's a nail
Hans is probably the rich northerner
that the Southerner was talking about
hey I got rich in the South so does that
make me a southerner I was poor in the
north and to come down here to get rich
Tunas shouldn't be allowed on highways
is there a Joe Biden in the crowd today
that will come down and kiss Hans Kim
today
I think um
I think the south is uh
is great I went to school in the South I
think
the south is a place that you can go to
to do what you need to do in the world
um I think
it's great it's a great place for me
I've had a lot of great experiences in
the South you know a lot of my life has
been in the South now not that much
though I've only been in Texas two and a
half years I went to college four years
went back in the summer so and then a
year so maybe three years to five years
of my life
but what are you gonna do I'm not a
southerner I am uh I believe in
America being racist
and I believe in uh
other things that Southerners don't
usually believe in but
in other ways I'm very Southern
but it's not a contest to be Southern
otherwise everyone would just be
shooting each other and you know [__]
each other's cousins
um but yeah I don't I don't really
I don't really uh
I want to
debate my southernness
I don't claim to be that southern I
don't think that's a problem
I am
not I'm not uh trying to have stolen
valor stolen incest
um
yeah I mean
how many Xanax I have I've not really
taken Xanax I haven't really felt them
work
um
[Music]
so do you think we should have National
education standards
I mean when you have standards then you
have to
um you know have like standardized
testing and all that I don't think
standardized testing is good because
then it just becomes all about the test
and then you teach for the test
I think kids aren't machines that just
have to get a certain grade I think
education is a rich organic process and
I think the more money you pump into it
the better it gets I don't think that we
have uh budgeted correctly for our
education system I think it could be
improved with money
standardization I think is um
I don't think is is that important I
think you give people money
and then you hope they do the right
thing with it if you see or hear things
the thing with schools is that parents
are always going to be up in their
business so if someone's doing some
[__] [__] in schools
you know hopefully the parents will
alert you know people and then the
proper procedures will be taken to
improve the school
but I don't think that we should be like
oh this school has got bad grades we
should uh you know pour more money into
it I guess
or we should give them less money it's
like oh if you don't your students don't
do well then you don't get like what is
what is going to be the incentive
I mean just publishing the results and
having a contest between schools could
be good but that's also kind of toxic to
make kids compete against each other
for industry of Education I think just
I think you just need a a person
to uh
teach kids the basic things and then I
think they should be out there seeing
what jobs exist and shadowing people at
jobs
maybe like
but yeah yeah I don't know about sending
kids off to random places in the world
um but yeah I mean maybe that's where
Holograms come in or VR
you know you can just take a VR goggle
and have like a representative go look
at or maybe just watch documentaries all
day about people at their job but the
thing is that we don't want to see what
people actually do all day we don't
categorize it we don't like
uh you know itemize what everyone's
doing because we know that people are
just wasting their time for the most
part if you have a better job that means
most of your work is useless if you're
poor that means you're doing things that
are actually useful to the economy but
if you're richer you're just sitting
around doing nothing so people that hire
people and like you know they don't want
to have like an accurate record of what
people do so then the schools are just
left in the blind because the offices
are just wasting people's time and they
don't want anyone to know so like yeah
they're busy they're doing the budget
and the the Excel and they're moving
cells around so then the schools have no
idea they're like okay let's teach them
you know how to count really high or to
like subtract a lot from a little or a
little from a lot or divide different
things together
and they're like hopefully that'll help
for the school for the real life for
their jobs and then like we learn a
bunch of theory and stuff that nerds and
losers who become teachers no offense to
teachers think is important
but yeah I mean I'm sure teachers are
are cool I'm sure there are some cool
teachers it's like
it can't be too hot as a teacher though
that's like an industry where you gotta
hire Algos
if you have like a banging teacher it's
like uh this is a lawsuit waiting to
happen
someone's gonna [__] you someone's Gonna
Wanna [__] you and hopefully you don't
want to [__] them so
if you're hot in the school you gotta
have
you gotta have a lot of skills
but yeah I think um
ugly people should should be more
utilized in Industries where sex is a
problem
like you know
you don't want to have too much sex
going on in Catholics churches so just
hire ugly people
and then if they're ugly enough a kid is
going to be like wait this is wrong if
it's like a hot priest and they're
touching you you're like oh well of
course this is a person that is touchy
because they're hot but if it's like an
ugly priest then it's gonna be like
yikes this is setting off warning Bells
even in my childlike mind this is not
right so they're gonna
freak out and they're gonna not get
molested as much it's like putting a
bell on a bear
wait you're supposed to put a bill on
yourself
they should really put bells on bears
but then they're gonna go hungry because
they can't sneak up on anything
um
do you think it's fair for a teacher to
be fired for an only fans
I mean there's so many people not doing
only fans and we could hire teachers
from there it's not like we're desperate
for teaching I'm extremely we kind of
are
um but yeah I don't think that's a good
thing to
have someone who's super sexual
professionally
be a teacher
but um
I don't think that it necessarily has to
connect the Two Worlds you could be a
professional porn person at night and
then teach kids but it's like
if you're in the middle of a class
session thinking about like
some giant beautiful vagina or dick then
it's like
I don't want adults thinking about
genitals in front of children so
they're going to be on only fans they're
going to be thinking about
dicks and boobs and vaginas a little bit
more than the average person so if you
want to limit the number of sexual
thoughts around children
as a way to stop sexual molestations
around children then
I think uh yeah I mean are we all hands
on deck is this like a pressing issue
of teachers [__] their children their
students
I think when it happens it's big news
but I don't think it's
I don't think it's the norm
I think most schools nobody no teachers
[__] children
I would say about
95 of schools don't have any students
getting [__] by teachers I think it's
only about five percent
of schools where
teachers are
statutory statutory raping their
students
and uh yeah I mean I don't think uh only
fans is like the best thing to do
all the time I mean I think it's great
if you like to show off your body and
all that and you want to make money off
of it it's just like I don't think it
should be as prominent as it is I think
the only reason why there's so many
um people doing only fans and why it's
such big news is because there's no
other options
I mean there's it's become a better
option because of the lack of other
options
and it's just a sad state of our economy
where our the women in our generation
have to sell their bodies because we
don't uh we're not running anything and
we're not in charge of anything and we
don't have any money from the previous
generation
we don't get to use the tools of
Technology we just have to
show off our bodies with webcams thank
you for the webcams that's the only
thing the Boomers have given us
here are some webcams now film
yourselves being [__]
Yes master I would love to get money
from you please
this is actually a good job this is a
good thing that I'm doing I'm [__]
over the system
because the alternative is so much worse
of sacrificing your health and mental
health
for a stupid minimum wage job
women choose to do only fans but if we
had a better economy there would be
fewer that make that choice so it's like
oh hey if we move this lever in society
we create a different kind of society I
wonder what kind of Leverage we could
move to create a better society and then
you realize that Healthcare is a good
idea
um but it's like yeah do you want to
have a wild west when you know the
outcome of that or do you want to like
play with the levers a little bit
I know that there could be corruption
people could be like oh let me change
the levers to give myself more money but
if you don't use the levers at all then
you fall into disrepair and you don't
like
then you don't do obvious things that
would help like building plumbing and
fresh water supply and all that like
that takes some degree of thought so if
we're gonna be buildings water supply
lines why don't we try thinking a little
bit harder about what other things we
could do but I don't think the answer is
to do nothing and to have the government
do absolutely as little as possible
because we know the outcome of that is
ghettos and private corporations running
everything in small
small uh groups of people with special
interests building highways wherever
they want
I don't think better economy is what
will stop only fans I think only fans
would be helped it wouldn't be a talk as
toxic I think people would come out at
it from a power a power position so it'd
be cooler there'd be people doing cooler
[__] with their vagina they're like oh
look at this vagina it's it's doing
happy flips instead of vaginas that are
sad and desperate and they're just
you know they're doing whatever sad
desperate vaginas do probably sticking a
lot of things in it
Universal basic income is uh
uh fun idea I would love to see it work
I mean
we should have some corner of the world
where they're doing it and I think they
are in some corners of the world but
it's like we don't all have to be doing
the same thing it's like everyone has to
be doing the same version of capitalism
if you don't do it this certain way then
that means you're doing it wrong and you
get a coup it's like why are we why are
we maintaining a uniformity and like uh
uh you know like a mono culture of
governments and economic structures we
should have a large variety but any
variety has to pass the scrutiny of
America
be like I don't think you're doing it
right so no you can't do this try this
guy Pinochet he knows a better way to do
it he's a great guy
huh
they will all love each other and do the
right thing if you give them a chance no
matter okay dude I mean what other
choice do we have like if you're not
going to trust people then you're going
to trust certain people at the end of
the day you have to trust people at some
point
so why don't we just trust people be
like okay we're gonna do the thing we're
gonna give each other power and I'm not
talking about nuclear bombs for everyone
I'm talking about democracy and voting
for
public transit and irrigation channels
and all that
but just to like be distrustful to
humans and be like oh they're gonna [__]
it up eventually is like well then let's
[__] it up right away so that we don't
have to prolong this if we're doomed to
failure then we should just fail but I
mean we've been doing good so far
so why why would we uh why would we just
start stop trusting humans at this point
when we've already come this far
I like when you're racist
um
I mean I was pretty racist about
Mexicans
so uh providing health insurance from
your job is how they control you that is
a great way to control people apparently
but apparently it was a consolation
prize for unions unions were like come
on give us health care and then whatever
the corporations the lobbied interest or
whatever were like no no health care at
all and they're like okay but how about
through our jobs then they're like okay
so you know maybe they shouldn't have
fought for that maybe if they were just
like okay no Health Care
then we would have fixed it eventually
or it would have we would have had like
some sort of fake National Health Care
system that would have grown
or else people would just die for some
reason Health Care is a really big deal
we just have to get health care figured
out
because
it's just so much more efficient to have
people alive
than suffering
I think healthcare is so great I think
when people are not dying then they act
better and death should be avoided for
most people until they can't it
shouldn't be a constant chronic thing
that they're thinking about
um
do artists have a role in helping
Society I think artists are a society I
think we're all artists Society is art
art is society
I think um
I think art is just so beautiful and as
an artist I have to say that art is so
artistic ever gotten into Anarchist
thought history
um not really
so something that is crazy is
[Music]
um
ugly people have to change and be
different hot people can be them be one
personality trait for as long as they
want
like uh people are like hmm I'm here I'm
being hot okay I'm here I'm being hot I
don't have to change I can just be
myself oh I'm in the post office I'm
still being hot but ugly people are like
oh I'm in the poster here's the postal
postage stamp and all that and then
they're at a meeting like oh hey I'm a
professional businessman yes
but how people are just hot
being hot is the best state of mind to
be in so they're just like I'm so hot
right now wow look how hot I'm being
and then um
ugly people are just
well they can't be hot so that they go
home and then when they're at the post
office they're like oh yes I get to be
at the post office I'm not ugly anymore
I'm ugly at the post office
but hot people They Don't Really
relegate they don't demote themselves to
post officeness
because they're already at hotness
for people that are ugly being uh
you know being at the post office is
better than being ugly
but hot people are just one mood all the
time hot hot hot hot and then they go
around and they're like why isn't this
on
I can't be hot if this [__] thing
isn't on I'm too hot right now
physically I mean like temperature wise
to be hot sexually
so then it's like
then it's like oh [__]
she's not hot anymore she needs the
temperature to be correct and then she
can go back to being hot
I don't know why you made her not be hot
sure my state of mind isn't in hotness
anymore
she's tired now she's not entire she's
in tired mode now she's not hot anymore
this is not okay
she could be hot and now she's being
tired
oh she can't find her sweatpants or
Keys watch out
she's doesn't have her things she's not
hot right now she's just looking for her
keys hot people shouldn't have to look
for Keys someone find her keys for her
right now
um
oh someone got mad at me because I
didn't recognize him when we met six
months ago
it's like sorry I forgot you we didn't
meet up every month
I mean if we're meeting up every month
then I'll remember you but if it's been
six months I'm sorry
I forgot you
if it's been over six months and we
haven't met again
you're not real to me anymore it's
that's not a real person like you can't
get mad at me for not remembering that
there's been so much to happen unless
there was like something that you did
that was crazy it's how am I supposed to
Remember You
like don't you understand that uh
you know some people
aren't gonna remember you all the time
I guess memory like
important it's the only disability that
you can make people feel guilty for like
sorry I have a bad memory
and then they're like no but it's me you
have to remember me I'm like so
important I'm the main character how
could you not remember me
I'm sorry it's just not something that
I'm good at I'm not good at remembering
people
like no no this has to be personal
I'm so interesting like there's no way
you could have ignored me
you could have forgotten me
it's like no I'm just sorry I'm just uh
physically incapable of forming memories
and they're like
well I'm gonna choose to take it
personally so
I'm gonna judge you I've always wanted
to treat someone like [__] and now I
have a great excuse
you insulted me you acted like I didn't
exist like I was dead you've uh reminded
me of my mortality and now because I was
dead to you
it made me mad and insecure and sad and
now I'm going to attack you
I'm going to be violent emotionally
and physically if possible
because you forgot me because you didn't
remember me
it's like I mean I think it's a good
thing because that means that they cared
about me enough to remember me
they're like oh we didn't share the same
connection you mean that there was an
asymmetry in my in our connection to
each other
it's like yeah I mean haven't you
wanted to [__] a hot girl that didn't
want to [__] you back and she was your
whole world and
you know it's like it's okay when that
happens it's like oh my God I'm like
nothing to this person it's like kind of
cool it's like it makes you feel sad in
a good way where you're like
none of my feelings matter
everybody doesn't respect me
and then you're like oh man
it's okay
all the pain that I went through didn't
even matter anyways doesn't matter man
it doesn't matter how sad you are you
just gotta be happy to be yourself
whatever
and then you achieve happiness like when
someone that I know forgets me
and I'm like
oh damn I'm not really memorable that's
okay that's not really one of my things
that I'm aiming for I'm aiming for
you know
I'm aiming for smart
uh talented skilled
a voracious lover memorable I guess if
I'm some of those then I will be
memorable but you know if I'm not it's
like hey you know I'm not always
smart or talented or skilled so
it's okay because I can be that later
but for that moment I wasn't which I
know that I do have those moments
and then like um
voracious lover I'm always a voracious
lover so
that one's not a problem for me
so my girlfriend called me at 8am last
this morning
and I went to sleep at like 2 30.
A.M
so five and a half hours into my journey
of sleep I get a phone call
I think I got a phone call at three she
said she called me at three and we were
on the phone for three hours I was dead
asleep I don't remember it at all
but yeah sometimes my girlfriend will
call me at 8am
and
I'm annoyed
I like my sleep
and she gets mad at me if I put it on
silent mode she likes to be able to
bother me anytime just in case of danger
but you know I'm I'm flattered that she
would decide to call me at 8am
foreign
but yeah I don't know I uh I don't like
being woken up at 8am
um
yeah it's just sleep
it's not that important ever since I've
been in a relationship sleep has been uh
de-prioritized
which I prioritize it pretty highly so
maybe that's just a different standard
but yeah I've had to sacrifice sleep to
be with someone which I would never have
done
I don't think I would have ever done
that I'd be like sorry
not hanging out tonight
so you know it's real
I love people in green rooms judging you
for if you're being a good person or not
it's like
are you being respectful to everybody
are you
being egotistical right now I love that
there's extra pressure to be like
you know
there's there's a pressure to be a good
person
and then you're just like trying to be a
good person in the Green Room
which is very important to be a good
person
but yeah there's people that are just
like staring at you just waiting for you
to [__] up
um but um really The Green Room isn't a
place for uh people to assess character
and and moral flaws it's more of a place
to prepare for the [__] show that I'm
about to do
oh great I get to be judged before I go
get judged
um but yeah I mean it is important to be
a good person so I'm glad that that
pressure exists
but I would also like a little chill
environment where people aren't just
existing
and stuff
but yeah I think it's good to uh
good to de-stress and just let loose in
the green room and just be like hey [__]
you get out of here or something to like
your good friend and be like hey you're
a little [__] bucket
and
tomorrow
what girls want is to be hot
anything else is just to distract people
from the fact that all they want to do
is be hot
I mean not every girl wants to be hot
but being hot is probably a really cool
thing to be if you're a girl
it's probably the ideal best thing for
you to be is hot and everything else is
just oh and she's a paleontologist
it's like a Barbie
um
so yeah I mean I think uh
I think women are amazing people and I
think that they should um really come
out of their shell and just start
kicking ass
[Music]
um
I uh
okay
um
that was it thank you guys so much for
coming out
for coming tuning in
not turning out
stretch before bed and your sleep will
improve and doing that lately and I wake
up way more energy it seems like a lot
of work
what I like to do before I go to sleep
is not do any work
I like to just sleep just crash
okay all right thank you